even left-wing mayor's are beginning to
admit the experts got it wrong way more
people have the virus than they thought
way fewer people are dying from it and
the lockdowns likely aren't doing very
much of anything to stop it
then the price of oil plummets to
negative $40 cancel culture claims
another scalp and Kim jong-un might be
brain-dead all that more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
Kim jong-un might be brain-dead
our experts definitely our brain dead
but the Kim jong-un might be brain dead
they say only the good die young you
know I know that you're not exactly
shocked to find out that the experts
might be wrong again
wrong and the infection numbers wrong on
the death rate wrong on the efficacy of
the lockdowns
wrong on everything why is it that all
the smartest people in the lab coats
with all the fancy degrees are wrong and
Joe Schmo who doesn't have any
particularly stunning stellar education
happens to be right this happens more
often than you would think gets to a
real truth about politics and the left
and the right we'll get to that in a
second first I got to thank our friends
over at ring you know whether you own a
home or an apartment or you live in a
nice neighborhood or a not-so-great
neighborhood you want to have eyes on
your front door ring gives you
protection at every corner it helps you
create custom affordable security for
your home ring detects motion when
people come onto your property and rings
video doorbells let you answer the door
and check in on your home anytime from
anywhere so as you know sweet Elise is a
very good shot I feel safe when I'm out
of town but I want to be able to check
in I really I believe in rings so much I
give it out to my friends as
housewarming gifts and they love it too
and the reason I do that is it
especially they move into a new
neighborhood it helps them see the
neighborhood they've all reported that
they love it and for me the thing I love
it's not that expensive so it looks like
a really really amazing gift and it is
all new ring video doorbell three is
upgraded with additional security
features and it works on any home get a
special offer on one of rings video
doorbells right now when you go to ring
calm slash Knowles start building custom
security for your home today the welcome
kit includes the ring video doorbell 3
and chime Pro that is ring.com slash
Noel's canna WL e s so the experts were
wrong on everything we got the latest
bit of evidence for this from
Mayor Eric Garcetti in Los Angeles last
night Eric Garcetti is backing up
something we've heard from other places
around the country that the virus is
much much more widespread than anybody
thought today many of you followed the
antibody test conducted by USC in LA
County that we've been involved with I
brought the doctors last week to this
briefing dr. Simon ensued they shared
the first results of the first wave of
antibody studies to see what the
prevalence of Cova 19 in the general
population was by testing for the
antibodies that we generate in reaction
to kovat 19 and it showed that the rate
of kovat 19 infections far exceeds the
number of confirmed cases something that
we knew but now we're starting to get
data for it also points towards that
only a small percentage of adults in the
county have antibodies to kovat 19 the
number they came up with an initial
study was that 4.1 percent of the adult
population in LA County from this sample
but it was a representative sample our
kovat 19 positive or have been kovat 19
positive that would mean that our
mortality rate which we've been
measuring at about 4.5%
would be much lower it would mean many
more people have been exposed to the
kovat 19 virus of course and you might
be thinking well 4.1% infection rate
that's actually not that high I was
expecting 50% or 60% 4.1 percent is very
very high when you compare it to what we
had been hearing before so this is from
not just gar city but the LA County
Department of Public Health they say
infections this is their press release
by the way this is not journalism
covering it or some right-wing web site
infections from the new corona virus are
far more widespread in the fatality rate
much lower in LA County than previously
thought
approximately 220 1000 to 442 thousand
adults in the county have had the
infection that estimate is 28 to 55
times higher than the 70 994 confirmed
cases of kovat 19 reported to the county
so all the
models everything that we were basing
our numbers on was based on an infection
rate 55 times lower than what we're
actually seeing so if you just divide
very simply the number of people who
have died from coronavirus by the number
of people we thought had it then the
mortality rates pretty high if you
divide it but you know you've got the
the mortality rate the number of deaths
divided by 55 times the number of people
we thought had it then obviously it's
much lower this backs up what we see out
of Stanford je Bhattacharya and other
scientists up at Stanford have done
similar tests and found similar numbers
for infection which were much higher
than previously thought which is by the
way what conservatives were saying weeks
ago and leftists were mocking us for
this backs up what we saw in
Massachusetts obviously that was right
in the heart of the epidemic over there
we looked at those numbers yesterday
showed infection rates up to 30% or 35%
people who had antibodies which means
they had it before which you're gonna
get if you're in a real hot spot and you
know that varies city by city and state
by state
this proves two things one for most
people the virus isn't that bad for some
people it's bad particularly people who
are older who have underlying health
conditions but we were already talking
about how for the majority of cases
confirmed cases it wasn't that bad weeks
ago now we find out that it's actually
55 times as many people had it the vast
majority of them never even knew they
had it the vast majority of people who
have had corona virus haven't had any
symptoms or any symptoms that would have
made them even consider going to a
doctor now the second thing we can
conclude from this is the political
conclusion which is that once you know
that the hospitals are not going to be
overrun then the lock downs are useless
that's the conclusion from this these
studies in this press conference that
the left and the media don't want you to
think about the whole point of the lock
downs is to not overwhelm the hospital
system right so
it when we say lower the curve or you
know stop - what are they flatten the
curve that's what they say flatten the
curve that's not to reduce the number of
people who get the virus it's just to
slow it down so that you don't get this
huge spike of people and there aren't
enough hospital beds and people die
unnecessarily but the same number of
people are gonna get it either way so
now now once we know that it's so much
more widespread that's that it's going
gangbusters that it's it's so much
faster and it's spread
then the lockdowns actually aren't doing
anything we know that we're not going to
overwhelm the hospital system we didn't
overwhelm it in New York we have an
empty Javits Center and an empty
hospital boat if the if the virus rather
is spreading so quickly then we now know
it's gonna spread to everybody virtually
everybody before we get the vaccine in
18 months or two years so what's the
point of the lockdown even if you said
the point of the lockdown is to slow it
enough that we can get a vaccine and
will be better for people we're not
going to do that we now know it's
spreading too fast for that so the lock
downs are serving literally no purpose
mayor Garcetti tries to put a scary spin
on it and he does so unsuccessfully but
it would also mean that still more than
95% of us if this study is
representative still do not have that do
not have any potential immunity and are
still vulnerable to being able to catch
this disease and die from it yeah we are
still vulnerable but that's always been
the case right the argument was never
locked down the economy and then most
people won't get it that was never going
to be the case so sure we now know it's
a lot of people are going to get this
many people are going to get sick some
people are going to die
that was always the case that the debate
isn't over let people get sick or don't
let them get sick there is no debate on
that basically everybody's going to get
it a very small number of people are
going to get seriously ill and a smaller
number of people are going to die from
it I'm not happy about that I'm not
encouraging that that is simply an
unavoidable fact that the left is trying
to pretend is avoidable
through science capital s and progress
capital P but it's not and it gets to a
real divide in our politics we'll get to
that in one second and then we'll get to
the other effects the totally avoidable
effects of this lockdown but first I
gotta thank our friends over liquid IV
now is not the time to let your body get
dehydrated is it you've got to stay
healthy everybody is talking about
liquid IVs hydration multiplier you've
heard how much I love it I tell you
about this all the time don't I now you
might say Michael you need that
multiplier because right now you know
people want to keep their bodies and
tip-top shape sure one of the real
reasons though that I use it is because
there's really nothing else to do these
days but I have a few adult beverages
and when you have a few adult beverages
you got to you know stay hydrated so
liquid IVs energy multiplier tastes
amazing just like their lemon-lime
flavor you just mix it in water and you
drink it the energy multiplier gives you
a sustained energy boost with no crash
and liquid IV cellular transport
technology ctt delivers an option
optimal ratio of nutrients for more
efficient uptake enhanced rapid
absorption into the bloodstream gives
you lasting energy boosts fast I really
like it you powers your mornings fuels
your long days it's great for workouts
sure and if you're like me a little
irresponsible sometimes you stay out
late with the boys then it helps you the
next morning to get 25% off when you had
a liquid IV com use code Michael mi CH
AE L at checkout it's 25% off anything
you order on liquid IVs website go to
liquid IV dot-com enter promo code
Michael to save 25% get better hydration
and energy liquid IV compro Michael
don't wait start fueling your adventures
today the biological effect of the lock
downs at least in LA is nothing it has
done nothing you heard it from Garcetti
we're gonna get it the things spreading
faster than we thought many of us have
already had it very good chance you've
already had it so that's unavoidable the
economic effect is avoidable and it's
much much more devastating less than
half of adults in law
Angeles right now are currently employed
now you might just say that's LA it's
it's a city full of actors and writers
and they're not the most employed people
ever well that's not quite right you
know they're not employed in the careers
that they pretend that they're doing but
they often are employed you know they're
waiting tables there uber drivers
they're assistants they're doing jobs in
LA and now half of them are not because
this town is shut down
film production is shut down okay that's
a lot of people in one of the major
American cities specifically over 1.3
million la residents who were employed
just a few weeks ago are no longer
employed that destroys lives okay
especially when it lasts for a long time
it's not just the money it's not just
even the work it's not even just the
self esteem higher unemployment numbers
mean higher death numbers what I'm
saying we're comparing the effects of
the shutdown what if we had to shut down
what if we don't have the shutdown we
can get right down to brass tacks the
number of people who will die because
increasingly it is appearing that the
lockdowns
are not saving any lives these with or
without the lockdowns people who are
frail and older can just stay home they
don't have to go out now the lockdowns
don't appear to be slowing the spread in
any way that's going to prevent it from
reaching most population the economic
effects are killing people we can
quantify this every 1% hike in the
unemployment rate this according to the
data provided by the National Bureau of
Economic Research and the medical
journal Lancet every 1% hike in the
unemployment rate will likely produce a
3.3 percent spike in drug overdose
deaths it will likely produce a zero
point nine nine percent spike almost 1%
spike in suicides for every 1% uptick in
the unemployment rate now our on
employment rate is almost 20 percent
before this shutdown we had almost full
employment record high employment one
two three four all the way up just about
20 percent 22 and a half a million
Americans at least have lost their jobs
in four weeks if unemployment hits 32
percent totally plausible
then 77,000 Americans are likely to die
from suicide and drug overdoses as a
result of the layoffs that is way more
than have currently died from
coronavirus and the people have died
from coronavirus almost certainly would
have died from coronavirus had we done
nothing
overall the death rate for an unemployed
person is 63 percent higher than the
death rate for somebody with a job
unbelievable numbers this according to
the journal social science and medicine
63 percent higher now you might say well
Michael if we had done nothing if we
didn't have a lock down maybe the death
rate would be a little bit higher for
the next three months sure maybe but
what's the death rate gonna be once we
lift the lockdowns inevitably because
we're not gonna have a vaccine in time
it's gonna jump right back up almost
certainly at least that's what the
models are showing and you were telling
me to listen to the models two weeks ago
and yet we have concocted this
theoretical way to save people and as a
result we have guaranteed that many many
more people will die not very smart but
it tells you something about the way the
left and the right look at politics okay
the left loves experts the right does
not love experts and yet in this case
the experts were wrong
the diploma chasing yuppie poser I love
science with a capital S liberals we're
wrong and the skeptics were right just
take a little look at the facts here we
have two positions the left said we need
to shut down every single thing not just
this month not just next month we got to
shut it down for 18 months Zeke Emanuel
we're not going to have
Sene we can't reopen anything until we
have a vaccine that was the left the
right said we need to be careful take
precautions take care of people who are
who are sick and frail but get the
economy moving again
which of those two ideas do you think
was most reasonable we've got a lot of
evidence we've got a lot of conclusion
we can tell you exactly why the experts
are always wrong and why the Liberals
who love experts are always wrong but
first I gotta think our friends over at
Rock Auto I love Rock Auto if your car
is having trouble you got to go to Rock
Auto it is an absolute godsend
especially right now because brick and
mortar not exactly open these days
rockauto.com catalog is unique it is
remarkably easy to navigate rockauto.com
is everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet the only thing
I really even know what that is is new
carpet motor oil I kind of get what that
is whether it is for your classic or
daily driver get everything you need in
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door you know me I don't know that
much about cars I like nice cars I like
driving around in nice cars but I don't
know anything about them I would always
get ripped off at car parts stores where
I go to the car parts store they
wouldn't have the part they'd probably
go online to rockauto.com to get the
part then they charge me twice as much I
love Rock Auto two cos it's a family
business they've been serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years and they
also always offer the lowest prices so
it's not changing all the time gimmicky
kind of stuff like that go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and right
Knolls Cana wles and there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you this is a lesson that
conservatives should always learn that
liberals should always learn and
everybody in the middle should learn the
experts are always wrong
okay the left told us we need to shut
down everything for 18 months what's
what's the evidence their models showing
that two million people were going to
die and no one had it yet and we were
just at the beginning
conservatives said let's be careful but
let's not crash the economy what was the
evidence conservatives had we we looked
at this virus compared to other
pandemics didn't seem that virulent what
other evidence did we have that maybe
that would this was an overreaction
we've just never shut down the global
economy for an illness like this so that
was it we didn't have like fancy
scientists and lab coats and stuff
showing us right
we just had good old common sense and
history as our guide and it turned out
we were right liberals follow the
experts for the exact reason that the
experts are always wrong it is actually
the central weakness of the experts that
gets the Liberals to love the experts so
much government by expert is
progressivism that is liberalism that is
left ISM ok leftism holds that politics
is a science we've seen this since the
days of Karl Marx actually even a little
bit before Karl Marx and certainly ever
since him see the old idea the
pre-modern idea is that politics is more
of an art than a science it's a way that
we persuade people and we weigh
different ethical questions and we come
together and govern ourselves but in the
modern progressive era they've said no
no no forget all that silly old stuff
where you have debate and all that we
just have science we see with scientific
precision what politics is and so if you
just put the smartest people in charge
of politics you'll have a perfect
politics no more rancor no more debate
no more misery if you just get a lot of
data and you empower smart people we
will have perfect governance we can know
everything there is no limit to politics
that's the leftist idea makes sense
right the only problem with that idea is
that it has never been correct ever
anywhere in the world and it has always
been wrong and it has always failed but
in theory it's a really good idea in
theory makes total sense I get it the
only problem is in reality conservatives
have a different take than that
ok conservatives have this idea that
we're happy to listen to experts when
they've got some modest contribution to
their narrow field of expertise
we know however that the world is simply
too complex to govern it based on a
model it's too chaotic it's too crazy
it's it's not possible to put in all the
data points to perfectly model out the
whole world or to perfectly model out
global warming or two perfectly model at
a pandemic or two perfectly model out
systems that are terribly complex we
know fundamentally that politics is not
a science politics is actually the
opposite of a science science very
simple you get your hypothesis you
follow a method you find out if it's
true or false politics is the weighing
of different priorities do we need more
criminals in prison or fewer criminals
in prison there's no scientific answer
to that we have to debate what kind of
society we want do we want a more
orderly society or do we want a more
liberal society liberal meaning you know
you get away with more stuff what would
you like do we want to legalize drugs
and have a more permissive society or do
we want to control drugs and have a more
orderly society right there's no
scientific answer for those things do we
want to tax people way more and
redistribute their money and have a more
economically equal society or do we want
to reduce the tax rate and allow people
to keep more of their money and have a
freer society
there's no equation for that there's no
rigorous obvious scientific answer it's
just politics you just debate things
with your fellow citizen that's the
point of self-government that's the
point of government and politics
generally this is why the educated
country-bumpkin conservatives have a
better track record in politics than
those brilliant wonderful credentialed
rationalist liberals who worship at the
altar of the latest data fad because
novelties and fads are always wrong and
useless almost always that's what makes
them novelties and fads right if they if
they were really enduring things they
wouldn't
be fads where is tradition history those
have been tested through the ages those
are more durable those are more reliable
so it's it's kind of ironic the left is
always shocked about this in politics
that those deplorable irredeemable
irredeemable Rube idiots that the left
holds in such contempt are usually more
correct about politics than these fancy
liberals who are really rationalist and
who have read all of their David Hume
and who have read all of their Jeremy
Bentham and you-know-who who catch up on
the latest science journal right they
they should know better and yet they
don't it's all those deplorable idiots
that they hate those are the ones that
actually get politics a little bit
better in the left ends up looking like
fools look no further for evidence of
this then bill de blasio in new york
bill de blasio
a leftist progressive rationalist
scientistic guy par excellence he
decides in this pandemic he's gonna let
a bunch of criminals at a prison a lot
of criminals at a Rikers okay he's
pretty serious guys and he's gonna let
them out cuz during a pandemic what you
want as more criminals roaming the
streets and now he's just shocked that
those criminals are committing crimes
here's de Blasio's reaction we said
there would be you know a rigorous
monitoring effort as well and that has
been built up we do see some recidivism
I don't have the exact numbers we see
some I've not seen a huge amount but any
amount is obviously troubling and I
think it's unconscionable just on a
human level that folks were shown mercy
and this is what some of them have done
but you know it's a small number of
people it's unconscionable and and if
there's one thing that criminals are
known for it's their conscience you know
I always say this about criminals I say
they've just got such a well-developed
healthy conscience which is why they are
the people who by definition violate
their conscience it's unconscionable
what kind of consciousness does Bill de
Blasio have if he doesn't get that
so naive so narrow okay and this is what
the left does these are the geniuses who
want to control your healthcare they
think okay
too many people in prison people in
prison is bad we got to let people out
of prison we use any excuse to let
people out of prison right that is the
kind of the premise they're beginning
with is that the criminal justice system
is rigged it's unfair there are too many
crimes on the books too many laws so we
got it it's just if a criminal is in
prison it's wrong we got to let them out
of prison then they're shocked when they
find out that the criminals once they
get out of prison commit more crimes
that I'm not saying that the left I'm
not saying that the experts can't be
right unlike a few narrow matters the
trouble that they run into is when they
try to expand that to take into account
multiple categories multiple problems
multiple areas of government this is why
the left always thinks that if you've
got some environmental expert that he
should be the guy in charge of the EPA
or you've got some health expert he
should be the guy in charge of the FDA
or whatever no he shouldn't I know it
seems that way but actually those two
experts are the last people who should
be in charge of those departments
because the people you want in charge of
those departments are people who can see
beyond their narrow field of expertise
you want generalists in charge of that
who can see how those different
departments are going to work with the
rest of the government and they work
with other priorities that we have
you'll listen to the advice on that one
narrow area but then you've got to move
beyond that left can't do it another
great example of this comes from AOC AOC
who is thrilled that many many Americans
are losing their jobs and that the
entire American energy sector is
collapsing she's so happy she loves to
see it we'll get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
you I've got to thank you guys you know
we haven't done one of these in a while
on account of the virus we have got
backstage live coming up tomorrow at
7:00 p.m. est so 4:00 p.m. PST it's
gonna be coming ups gonna be a lot of
fun while you were locked in it is time
for you
to lock into this deal how's that for a
segue when you become a daily wire
insider plus or all-access member you
will get not one beautiful daily wire
leftist ears tumblr you will get wait
for it wait for it - that's right one
for you and one for corn pop and for
existing members I know you're probably
feeling a little envious right now don't
worry we have a special offer coming up
just for you you get everything in the
daily wire you know exactly what you get
me then drew Matt you can get the all
access to your which is a new show that
we've been doing it's a ton of fun
people have asked me to do an Elvis
impression on that show coming up maybe
I'll do that soon I don't know
guess you'll have to subscribe to find
out you get so much more go to daily
wire calm right now / subscribe to get
started you get 10% off with coupon code
Knowles that is daily wire calm /
subscribe coupon code Knolls 10% off to
leftist ears Tumblr's we're losing money
on this deal head on over there we'll be
right back with a lot more
so the oil industry has collapsed the
American energy sector which has been
doing great in recent years we're
finally now producing our own energy
remember for how long we were dependent
on Middle Eastern oil that led to some
foreign policy difficulties now we're
doing great the American energy sector
is doing great except it just collapsed
oil was trading yesterday at negative
$40 per barrel negative 40 so they would
pay you to take the oil off of their
hands wish I could have gotten my hands
on a few barrels to fill up with all
that free oil now this is a big deal
this is a bad thing you do not want the
American energy sector to go belly-up
it would have horrible national security
implications put thousands and thousands
of Americans out of work it already has
it's just really bad unless your AOC AOC
thinks it's great she tweets out
yesterday in response to evidence that
the oil prices are now negative values
and the industry is going belly-up quote
you absolutely love to see it
this along with record low interest
rates means it's the right time for a
worker led mass investment in green
infrastructure to save our planet
so narrow all she's thinking about is
her fantasy of global warming this
theory that theoretically the Sun
monsters gonna kill us in 12 years well
she said that a year ago so what is it's
11 years now we'll see they notice
they've been predicting imminent demise
for the last 50 years and they always
seem to push back the timetable let's
say it were true let's say let's say
that the Sun monster's gonna kill us in
10 years I don't think it will but let's
say that everything else he's saying
about global warming were true there's
no way you can address that if you
destroy the entire American energy
industry right the green New Deal gets
rid of American 90% of American energy
at least bans virtually every form of
transportation and then they say that
they're gonna remake every house in
America every building in America and
make it green and that's going to save
the planet
how you gonna redo every single house in
America if you get rid of all the
transportation and the energy it's just
not possible even by their own premises
you can't achieve their ends if you do
what they want you to do but that's what
happens when you're really narrow you're
only viewing every issue through this
very slight frame of reference with
regard to environmentalism and you end
up losing that too
just think of the advertisements that
Republicans are going to be able to make
on this how did Democrats blow it
Democrats have the entire media they
have the entire bureaucracy they have a
global pandemic that that they can use
to make Trump not look so good they've
got 20% unemployment and yet they're
blowing it they're blowing it because
they're disconnected from reality
they're blowing it because of their
trust in the experts they're blowing it
because they want to destroy whole
American industries to pursue goals that
you can't pursue without those
industries they're blowing it because
they'd rather certainly throw millions
of Americans out of work certainly
increase their death numbers then save
people's lives in theory it's that
disconnect there was this old line about
the left they would say who cares if it
works in practice does it work in theory
right they want to make sure the
theoretical aspect works they're living
in a theoretical world they're ignoring
the real world in front of them and
meanwhile back here in reality President
Trump and his supporters are having a
field day just look at the ads that they
are already running this is an ad about
the lockdowns about Nancy Pelosi eating
her fancy ice cream at over 20,000
dollar fridge while they're gleefully
allowing millions of Americans to go out
of work we turned out of that 350
billion dollar fund to help small
businesses and its workers get through
the shutdown it will be up to Congress
to restock it but Democrats blocking
that move this morning they asked for a
quarter of a trillion dollars in 48
hours as well
think so they objected and I
congratulate the Senate Democrat speaker
Pelosi what are you gonna share with us
from your home chocolate candy thousands
have been forced to wait for hours at
food banks all across the country Oh
chocolate and then we have some other
chocolate here we just got it restock
the ice cream you don't want to eat up
everything know it at one time I can't
do it much longer I'm trying so hard can
we say enjoying having to admit that
yeah what we're starving and I like it
better than anything else
taping this segment there are 22 million
people out this specific program is
about stopping job losses today other
people in our family look for some other
flavors but I know it's survival mode
you don't know what makes something else
about come from I don't know what I
would have done if ice cream and not
invent it I just wondered oh that is a
brutal ad I mean the last line is let
them eat ice cream Nancy Antoinette who
would film this this segment you know
she did this segment for a late-night
show where she goes here's my fridge
here's my really nice fridge with all my
chocolate ice cream I mean it's a bad
look during a pandemic when millions of
your countrymen are going out of work
I'm not saying you can't eat ice cream
not saying you can't on a nice fridge
it's just a bad look to flaunt that
during the pandemic but two leftists
like Pelosi two leftists like all the
people in the mainstream media egging on
these lock downs to those people this
this lockdown doesn't mean anything none
of them are missing a paycheck none of
them know they all have nice houses so
they it doesn't even matter that they
can't go outside nothing has changed
they can all do their work from home
they've all got white-collar jobs they
can do all their meetings on zoom' it's
actually fine you know for certain
people the lockdown is well okay they
lost let's say they lost ten grand in
the course of this okay whatever it
doesn't matter to them and so when they
see people protesting against the
lockdowns
protesting to go back to work protesting
not to lose their businesses they look
on them
with not just contempt but bewilderment
so what are you doing why just stay home
and you know eat your dove ice cream
bars and just sit back and watch some TV
and watch the money fill up in your bank
account what's the big deal you're a
maniac you're gonna kill us all my dove
is so delicious mmm love that chocolate
they don't realize that people are
reacting to real problems which is that
they don't have any more money okay
twelve hundred dollars that they got
from the federal stimulus that goes like
that
okay that's gone okay rent done pay off
part of your credit card bill done it's
gone okay now what the small business
money that the Democrats are refusing to
refill Democrats force the government to
shut down force people out of business
tens of millions of Americans rely on
small businesses for their jobs small
businesses run on generally pretty small
margins money runs out oh whatever
that's okay we'll get back we'll get
back to Washington when we're ready okay
well I haven't finished all my chocolate
ice cream bars it's such a bad look that
you could only buy into if you are
disconnected from the realities that
people are facing and that is how during
a pandemic with 20% unemployment somehow
Trump's approval ratings are still doing
great because at least that guy looks
like he's working for people exact looks
like he's listening to people and the
left simply does not now obviously
Republicans are gonna have a field day
with these ads going into November
they're already doing that beyond just
that coronavirus adds beyond just
knocking Pelosi there's an ad that Trump
put out yesterday I guess it's an ad
it's really more of a meme and the meme
is it's an Allstate ad like for Allstate
car insurance and it's these people
sitting around watching the game and
then an Allstate commercial comes on and
they turn to the guy who's in the
commercial and they kind of knock him
for the commercial interrupting the
basketball game so in this ad they put
Barack Obama's face on one of the guys
and the thing that they're all watching
on TV is Obama's sad endorsement of Joe
Biden you know it cuts to Joe Biden just
kind of rambling on incoherently and
they ask them like what on earth are you
thinking here's the ad
not another commercial the kids used to
come up reach and pull and rub my leg
down so it's training that watch the
hair come come back up again
they look at so I learned about roaches
I learned about kids jumping on my lap
[Music]
so this is the take on that ad with the
old State spokesman Dennis Haysbert man
you know Obama's face is on there do you
know what people said about this ad you
know what the left is said I'll give you
one guess one word two syllables take a
guess it's what they call everything
that they don't like they called it
racist so of course everything bad is
racist people said it was written up how
is it racist just try to think about
that very easy to say it's racist not
easy to explain how it's racist is it
racist because there were black people
in it is it is it racist now to put
black people in an ad that maybe that's
what they're saying I don't think that
makes a lot of sense is it racist
because it kind of mocks Barack Obama I
mean we were told for eight years that
mocking Barack Obama is racist now
obviously that's not true
so okay you try to think you're like
okay there's nothing racist about this
even though all the little blue
checkmarks were saying that it was
racist maybe it's because there's a rap
song at the end it's rap is it racist if
white people use rap is that racist
no no probably not what was the rap song
by the way because this gets this gets
to trump strategy here so the rap song
if you couldn't hear it is let me clear
my throat by DJ cool back in there the
Golden Age of hip-hop and what are the
lyrics to it
lyrics are jump right jump jump jump
some of you all know how to do this and
some of you don't and let me clear my
throat that's the name of the song why
do they choose let me clear my throat
the whole ad is about how Joe Biden
can't speak and how he's rambling and
how he doesn't know how to talk and him
so the song let me clear my throat is a
joke about this and it's also let me
clear my throat like this sort of
surprised at what has happened the whole
ad is about the surprise that Barack
Obama would actually endorse Joe Biden
and Obama turns in here's what what come
on what's the deal the the lyric that
they actually used for the song is
jamming and crammin the party people in
the dance floor they want to see why GFC
was called for shaken and breakin
no mistaken the identity you know the
man with the plan and the remedy and
really what we're seeing here in in all
of Trump's advertising not just this one
but in all of trumps materials on the
general election is in some ways a redo
of what we saw in 2016 it's just this
dichotomy Trump high energy opponent Low
Energy
Trump is the man with the plan and the
remedy Joe Biden doesn't have any energy
he can't speak he doesn't know what's
going on you see this Trump actually
corrected himself the other day when he
said look when I ban travel from China
Joe Biden went crazy no excuse me he
didn't go crazy
he can't go crazy he doesn't know where
he is he doesn't have any energy right
he actually caught himself because the
image he's portraying of Joe Biden is an
accurate one which is that he's got no
stamina he's got no endurance he's just
exhausted so that's the key here
so you turn up some very high energy
hip-hop jump-jump-jump I'm the man with
the plan in the remedy just gives you
this image of an energetic campaign all
of that said the Trump campaign was
definitely trying to bait the left into
calling this racist so that the left
would look ridiculous because they can't
explain why it's racist they do this a
lot all right Trump totally knows how to
do this when Trump during that press
conference last week when he came out
and said I'm gonna use my constitutional
authority to adjourn Congress that was
bait okay he was putting the bait out
there for all the Talking Heads and all
the leftists and the fancy suits and
ties to come out and say this is
unconstitutional and then immediately
the Trump campaign comes out with first
of all the article the section of the
Constitution that gives him the power to
do that but there was also a New York
Times article from the 60s from the
Kennedy administration that said that
the president has the power to adjourn
Congress it was a bait and then he gets
to smack him down and that's what he's
doing all the time like they are around
his little finger why how does this work
because it's very easy to understand the
left's ideology this is why John hight
the social scientist was able to show a
few years ago that the the right
understands the left much better than
the left understands the right well the
reason for that is its this is not just
some mark of pride and we can say we're
so much smarter than the left the reason
for that is very simple it's what we've
been talking about all day it's because
the left has this narrow ideology a
rationalist ideology the experts are
always right it's easy to understand
that right it's a very clear ideology
shallows are clear like dr. Johnson said
shallow thinking is really clear so we
can understand it whereas the right it's
very hard to understand what the right
things is the right is a very complex
view of the world right the right looks
around and says the world is I can't
just put this on a manifesto on a sheet
of paper so they say it's racist another
you know another great example of how
everything's racist Land O'Lakes butter
no Land O'Lakes butter how can that be
racist it is apparently they just
changed their logo Land O'Lakes us the
the butter where it's got the very like
pretty Native American woman on the
cover and they took that off that's
racist they apparently that the logo had
long been criticized as racist and
stereotypical the North Dakota
representative Ruth Buffalo said that
the image goes hand in hand with human
and sex trafficking of our women and
girls human and sex strip man I got to
look more closely at that Land O'Lakes
image because to me it looks like a
smiling nice pretty Native American
woman holding up a box of butter sex
trafficking what well when you've got
this kind of crazy narrow ideology the
ideology that you know any everything
and anything is racist sexist
misogynistic then you can say those kind
of absurd things and to the rest of us
obviously it makes them look ridiculous
and elope we're not all even allowed to
mention Native Americans now isn't that
kind of racist too to take Native
Americans off of imagery
I don't know everything's racist I guess
before we go got it quickly get to the
dumbest article on the Internet today
this is from the New York Times from
Charles blow he's appeared in this in
this segment many times he's won the
award on numerous occasions it's called
stopped airing Trump's briefings stopped
airing Trump's prunes the media is
allowing disinformation to appear as
news the premise of this article is that
the briefings the Trump is giving every
day communicating to the American people
they are misinformation deceptions rage
blaming and boasting and Charles blow
complains a little bit more says it's
disinformation flanked by scientists and
officials whose presence only serves to
convey credibility to propagandistic
performances that have simply become a
replacement for political rallies they
think it's they think its credibility
that they're those scientists are giving
that's not true they think the
scientists give credibility to Trump not
true Trump gives credibility to the
scientists because we most sensible
Americans prioritize and value our
political system above the vaunted
opinions of labcoat experts who are
usually wrong about everything but the
left doesn't get that we're in the
middle of a pandemic but we're in the
middle of a campaign let me be clear
under no circumstance should these
briefings be carried live doing so is a
mistake bordering on journalistic
malpractice and then you know what I
love Ted Koppel told the New York Times
old left-wing journalist he said
training a camera on a live event just
letting a play out is technology not
journalism journalism requires editing
in context the question clearly is
whether president obliges us to
broadcast every briefing unbelievable
they just admit it here in this article
everything we've been talking about
today they don't want to carry the
reality they don't want to hear the
reality unvarnished they want to craft
their own narrative that by their own
admission is different from the reality
that we're seeing different from what we
could look at with our own eyes and then
push the narrative no matter how
different it is from the reality and
that is why they're a bunch of laughing
stocks and that is why they keep on
losing before we go also last moment Kim
jong-un might be dead we don't know if
he's dead there are some intelligence
that he's either gravely ill
he's brain-dead or he was ill but he's
recovered we just don't know this may
very well have something to do with
coronavirus obviously North Korea is a
client state of communist China Chinese
scientists and doctors fly over there a
lot there's a possibility that this is
connected to the pandemic and it might
be connected to the pandemic in another
way which is that you know these
quarantine czar making people really
really lonely we turn now for reaction
to North Korean dictator Kim Jong okay
I'm getting word actually that that song
was being sung by Kim Jong Un's father
Kim jong-il not Kim jong-un and so I
just obviously wouldn't want to make a
gross characterization like that and say
that the two guys were similar I would
never want to offend anybody so I'm
please accept my apologies for that
mistake just before we go after all of
the press inquiries I would just like to
quell the speculation right now I have
no plans of becoming the supreme leader
of North Korea okay I know I know people
have been asking a lot no my name has
been floated a lot I'm really focused
right now on on these podcasts you know
I really love what I'm doing so I'm sure
Kim jong-un will make a full recovery
and I have no plans to become the next
dictator of North Korea for now that is
our show I'm Michael Knowles is the
Michael Knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there